[Music]
hey guys welcome to another episode of
congratulations
[Music]
yeah dude if you're just listening i
pumped my
freaking fist like that in the air
and if you're watching you know i did it
you know i did it so uh
because you saw me pump my fist in the
air uh yeah dude um you know what's
great man we got the merch out there
let's just start with this we got the
merch out there making friends in the
comments hoodies it's mint green oopsy
daisy we've got the tan life rips it's a
sandstorm life rips hoodie and we've got
the t-shirt oopsie daisy okay and we
also have got awesome merch coming out
later oopsie daisy we'll keep it on the
hush but that's what's up dude so go to
crystalia
almost throw up in my mouth and it's all
good and we'll leave it in dude i don't
take it out because i'm wrong what you
see is what you get okay and i know you
understand that
i'm coming from way back dude
i'm coming from way back i'm coming from
so far back you swear you hear hubba
stank i swear dude it's that nostalgia
it's that nostalgia [ __ ] you get when
you just hear my my voice full of soda
but um yeah dude you know i don't know i
had a day today where i you know what
let me tell it like pulp fiction like
the movie pulp fiction i'll do it
backwards
today
got a coffee woke up got a coffee all
good dude ate something uh it was like
spinach and eggs got another coffee all
good drank another coffee then got
nauseous forgot three days ago had a
problem with nausea and two days ago
[ __ ] my brains out so now
i'm reminded of those past two days
because of
how i um
you know i forgot i was nauseous and i
drank two coffees and if i had three
coffees and if i hadn't
if i had remembered that no if i had
remembered that would i have not
drinking the coffee yes i probably would
have had one but not three and that's
fine but i just told that story like
pulp fiction and you're welcome dude i
told the end first and then i went back
dude and that's how i do it man because
i'm really [ __ ] honestly
uh
i'm creative with podcasting you know
i did a lot of bodyweight exercises
today i'm sorry i'm sorry to break your
heart strong guys and that's fine you're
still there you exist you pump heavy
iron you exist i saw a picture of four
stacked dudes standing shirtless today
uh
on instagram just they were just done
with their workout and they looked
amazing and that's fine they obviously
pumped weights and that's all good but
your boy did body resistance and that's
fine but i'm starting to break your
heart strong guys
you know
i got [ __ ]
notices of uh production on my back over
here
it's [ __ ] insane dude so i'm sorry to
break your heart strong guys but let's
get it going let's start
and what should we start with well we
should start with this hey this island
boy guy everyone i this is a rare
occasion where i'm talking about the
thing that everyone is sending me i
don't normally do this i talk about what
i want to but i have to talk about this
because so many people
want me to talk about this i can't
believe how many people have sent this
to me
um and i'm going to play it because it's
unbelievable but it's really not
something that i even care to talk about
but i'm going to do it for y'all
because i'm an island boy and i've been
trying to make oh my islam boy
okay this guy's an apparently this guy's
an island boy okay this is fly soldier i
don't know this guy's name is fly
soldier and
kodiak red why do they do that why is
there a kodiak red when there's a
when there's a kodak black
it's like how when like lil nas was like
yen
i see your nas but i raise you a little
why are they doing this there's asap
rocky and asap ferg what you're doing
you're from the same group i get it
don't care
dude all the people from [ __ ] family
matters are the same group it's not
[ __ ] steve urkel and reginald urkel
they have their own names
um so this guy's an island boy and of
course i will say both of these guys
look exactly alike and they're both
white i think i don't even know and
tatted up and they have [ __ ] [ __ ]
coming out of their head so
i'm a just island boy
other guy
not helping at all
oh that's oh he's from florida go figure
other guy turn
wow in a jacuzzi their parents are i
guarantee their parents are so [ __ ]
rich
because we try home like a lion their
dad's an orthodontist you know the
island boy
their dad's the second most [ __ ]
successful orthodontist in all of
florida and the mom is a [ __ ]
high-class lawyer guarantee it dude
oh my god dude
okay so we got that part okay
dude i'm a [ __ ] island boy these guys
took my [ __ ]
dad's the [ __ ] most second wealthiest
orthodontist in all of florida and the
mom is a huge [ __ ] lawyer
and and everywhere the mom goes now
people are like oh i saw the island boy
thing with your kids it's really great
and she's like for [ __ ] sake dude this
is my legacy i've tried to [ __ ] free
innocent victims all the time and the
dad's like i've really been working on
some teeth my whole life and these
[ __ ] kids with [ __ ] coming out of
their heads [ __ ] think that they're
guaguan and the island boy
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude why were they even in
the jacuzzi with [ __ ] basketball
shorts on that's what they think all day
great
i gotta stop i gotta go to the bathroom
that story gave me ptsd i gotta go
really number two no [ __ ] i'll be
right back
i'm back guys and joke's on you i didn't
even go number two i just drew a picture
of four dragons um
so yeah dude we're back and uh i'm still
an on island boy
people who get face tattoos huh i'm not
sure dude
i'm not sure
maybe one how about that maybe one maybe
one
you know if you're like a convict and
you killed somebody you want a teardrop
and you're in prison for the rest of
your life or
or if something really means something
to you you know what i mean maybe one
but all the whole face
i saw a guy
on instagram the other day who had just
eye eye eyeballs tattooed all over his
the right side of his face some mistake
some mistake
what about what about meeting people
right
about that
um
anyway dude i'm an island boy i'm an
islam boy i'm a [ __ ] island boy
i'm just i'm just i limbo
i uh
i was that [ __ ] coffee bean today you
know what i did to just be disrespectful
respectfully disrespectful is i went to
coffee bean and tea leaf and i [ __ ]
got a coffee being a tea leaf and i
drove to starbucks and drank it
that's how he does it from now on that's
how he does it to let him know
that if you're the jets i'm the sharks
okay do you understand
when you're a jet you're a jet all along
you bring a coffee bean to the starbucks
to show them who's boss
you drink it sit by say hip to show em
who's boss
they say that they don't care
secretly it probably makes them feel
insecure
um worst musical ever so um yeah dude
so i brought a [ __ ] coffee dude i'm
sorry dude i'm sorry starbucks but i had
to do it to him
you know how they say
i had to do it to him this is what that
phrase was created for
getting
a coffee showing starbucks that they
need to start
making better coffee you know why
because that's what you do
it's what you do
starbucks guess what you do
you don't have to because you know you
make coffee
so make it good
right
i get it it's subjective but people
aren't going because it's good
people are going because this is
convenient right if there was a
starbucks in my house
wink
then i would never go to coffee bean but
that's what it would have to be
and since there's not a starbucks in my
house wink
i always go to coffee bean
if a starbucks was next door i'd still
go to coffee bean
so i did that [ __ ] i was gangster as
[ __ ] and you know i dress like a mob
boss i'm dressed like a fat [ __ ] mob
boss i dressed in
uh brown pants and a brown top that
matched they're from the same [ __ ] i did
that and i [ __ ] and i did it i was on
my fat [ __ ] my boss [ __ ] dude
so that's that man
and those are the kinds of things i do
and those are the kinds of things that
are important and you're sitting here
listening to [ __ ] npr right
everyone's mad at the wrong [ __ ] i've
said this for a long time dude you take
this dave chappelle special i talked a
little bit about it last time or maybe
you actually talked about on the patreon
episode but dude
netflix first of all
props to uh ted sarandos for [ __ ] not
pulling the thing all right
and i'm just gonna re it's like
you know
people talk about this very you know
they talk about it more eloquently than
me they talk about it but there's one
thing that is just true it's jokes okay
it's jokes and that's it that's all you
need to stop you need to stop it's jokes
so it's not hate speech okay it isn't
hate speech because no one's hating
disabled doesn't hate these people
or whoever he's talking about you know
it's the trans community at this time i
think that's really mad and he doesn't
hate them it's not hate speech because
it doesn't hate them it's jokes and it's
art art is supposed to make you feel
uncomfortable it's supposed to not
necessarily align with your values or
your thoughts it's supposed to it's art
or as calvin would say ah
okay
so
you can get mad all you want
we're in a time where it's
where we need to
make sure that the people who get mad
aren't the ones
who are [ __ ] changing everything
about [ __ ] the country the world
because when you're mad
you're
not regulated and when you're not
regulated you make bad decisions
okay
if i'm home i love pairs i tell chris to
get pears so much and she never comes
back with prayers i say how come you
don't get paired she says i forgot i
said how can we look at prayers i forgot
9 10 12 15 times pears no pears just
apples i get mad i get mad i take the
apples i throw the [ __ ] apples out
the window right that's just what i do
i'm mad i'm not regulated
there are ways to talk about this
and you know what here's the other thing
too it's not even really anybody's fault
but the media how about that
because 10 sarandos
after
after this happened on uh uh he said we
have no plans to pull it from netflix
you know and props to him for that and
then he was like uh he put out another
he put out this thing that was like you
know
it's just art relax whatever i'm
paraphrasing obviously he didn't say
it's just not relaxed but uh and then
later on he came out with the things i
realized that maybe what i said was
insensitive it wasn't the best thing to
say uh i'm sorry or whatever he said
right and i'm like oh [ __ ] now they're
gonna [ __ ] pull the special the
media's
had so i read the
before i say that so i read the the body
of the parrot the body of the uh the
subject and all the article and it's
it's it's not
that they're gonna pull the [ __ ]
it's he's like you know what we're still
not gonna pull it i realize i kind of
talked uh
insensitively i didn't mean to but
there's no plans to pull the special and
i'm like the way the media [ __ ] put
this on the headline was
ted sarandos is like stepping
back his
stance which is not what he was doing
so
when the media puts out headlines that
are that divisive you're just splitting
the [ __ ] country
it is by no means not the media's fault
this and there's the media's so mad at
joe rogan for [ __ ] being a guy that's
actually telling the goddamn truth at
least trying to as best he can he may be
wrong about a lot of things he may be
wrong about big things
but he's not [ __ ] you know what i
mean nobody's in his pockets
so you can get mad all you want but it's
not hate speech it's not hate speech you
know what is hateful
this this [ __ ] what happened here man
with a i saw this on
um
on uh
so so if the media calls it hate speech
it's like baiting the [ __ ] people who
feel like
they were hated or maybe not even
necessarily hated
it's baiting them to do something about
it it really is it's irresponsible it's
[ __ ] irresponsible
and they were looking at right here this
guy who goes to the protest because they
were going to organize a protest and
that happened today i think at netflix
where there was going to be a netflix
walkout and people were going to protest
them leaving
this dave chappelle special on netflix
by the way there's like [ __ ] 20
people there okay
and there's one guy shows up with with a
sign that says dave chappelle is funny
or some [ __ ] or i like dave okay and he
shows up this is it this is what i saw
[Applause]
[Music]
so a guy shows up
in a mask
not a [ __ ] like a richard nixon mask
of cover mask and grabs the guy's sign
from the guy and breaks it so now he's
now this dude who is peacefully
protesting doing exactly what they're
doing
comes and
ruins the guy's property right
check this out
[Applause]
[Music]
look breaks breaks his sign
breaks his sign so the sign comes off
now the guy's sitting there with his
broken
wooden stick and the guy
[ __ ] who broke his sign said he's got
a weapon
this is exactly
what is wrong
you created this [ __ ]
you created this this is something that
you created
you
bet you
with no
exaggeration
put a weapon in this guy's hand first of
all it's not a weapon okay it's [ __ ]
half a sign that you broke
and this guy breaks it
and [ __ ] says he's got a weapon gives
it back to the guy
you're planting evidence
it's just some dude with a beard showing
up saying he likes dave chappelle that's
what he's saying the sign says we like
dave he's not even [ __ ]
it don't even say chappelle he could be
talking to [ __ ] owner of wendy's
unbelievable dude this is unbelievable
where this i'm out dude
and i don't even i don't even
think
like
this is the problem dude
you take somebody who really doesn't
think about trans issues or whatever
issues it is that's at the [ __ ]
you know
heartbeat of the media right now
and
all of a sudden you thrust this
hey you need to be on the right side the
media is like you need to be on the
right side i did a bit [ __ ] months
ago about silence is violence silence
isn't violence dude some people just
want to shut the [ __ ] up
and and live
silent violence is violence
violence is breaking a guy's property
and shoving it in his hand saying this
is a weapon he has a weapon pushing that
guy back that's violence there's no
violence
what's hate
the guy showing up saying i like i like
i this is what i like i like dave
and i get it dude like people like
you know
i either get it or i don't but the the
trans community is marginalized and but
when the media says you're
if you're silent
you're adding to the violence you need
to pick a side you're only pushing the
people that might join that side further
from your side that's it
and it's so [ __ ] obvious that when i
talk about it i feel boring
that's the worst part
i feel like me talking about this is so
obvious that when i do i feel people are
gonna stop listening to my podcast not
because i'm being divisive but because
i'm being [ __ ] boring
that's how obvious it is
i mean dude it's laughable man
thank god they didn't pull the special
dude it's comedy i saw comedians saying
like we support the netflix walkout oh
dude you're a comedian
against
comedy
right
you're a [ __ ]
i mean dude
it's like you have a liquor store and
when they're delivering [ __ ] dos
equis you say
none of that here
that's what you're doing
if you're against
anybody saying anything in a comedy
special then that's where it starts
i i mean i can't you know i get it if if
you know chappelle was saying
i saw what he said it's like
it's just super weird all of it and it's
sad it's sad man
because these people are not regulated
here at this [ __ ]
protest
i don't know man it's lenny bruce all
over again also it's going to happen
again in 35 [ __ ] years it's just
going to happen again and again and
again and again and again and again
until an asteroid hits us and then oops
dinosaurs again
dinosaurs again cavemen again [ __ ]
all this [ __ ] all the way up to should
women vote yes they can and then again
and again and again and then again and
again and again until the new dave
chappelle comes out except he he's
called me black blue because that's the
[ __ ] names in the future and he's
just like hey check this out knock knock
knock knock knock and all the krev lords
are gonna be like no no you can't say
that oh
and [ __ ] shrink them down
that's a [ __ ] ray gun that shrinks
you down and there you go they're gonna
be like but silence is violence and
you're gonna be you're the ones with the
[ __ ] ray guns
remember dave chappelle
eat lord no they wiped our memories of
him leave or
lord wear your mask
what
kovid
4617 blake blark
oh no
we gotta [ __ ] think about this [ __ ]
when there's fun freaking [ __ ] in the
world to think about dude i gotta think
about guys breaking other people's signs
and causing violence saying you're being
your talking is violent so let me be
violent there that's [ __ ] violence i
gotta [ __ ] talk about this [ __ ] and
be hacking [ __ ] on my own podcast and
have you
click over to some mouse
i'm giving npr [ __ ] views and watches
when i talk about hack dog [ __ ] like
this
insane
i mean i [ __ ] saved that lineage of
speaking with the [ __ ] alien [ __ ] and
the meat more black blue in the
krevlor's and i [ __ ] dug deep in my
balls for that one
right
i'm
you know what i mean and i gotta talk
about it because people are like you
didn't say anything about the day
chappelle you didn't say anything about
islam
i forgot
waguang and i'm [ __ ] trying to talk
about the fun [ __ ] like what goddamn uh
russell wilson said the other day
but
you know what i mean
so let me save it
russell wilson the other day said
what are we doing dude here's my main
thing okay
not everybody has to have a personality
that's fine
we need things like wall street
football
cashiers
people who play frisbee golf
uh
people who own little figure rings of
like [ __ ] marvel
x-mens and [ __ ] you know what i mean
they collect those right
guys who think this is
something saying this is interesting oh
man classic
these are all people that don't have
personalities and that's fine but you
don't need to cultivate [ __ ]
if you're just some guy that thinks it's
a cool idea to have a [ __ ]
night have nights armor in your [ __ ]
den you know what i mean some guys just
have a [ __ ] this [ __ ] right like
definitely one of the [ __ ] uh
property brothers has a [ __ ] you know
what i mean i think they live in las
vegas
i if a [ __ ] if one of the property
brothers doesn't have [ __ ] knights
armor like somewhere in the vicinity of
his for foyer honestly i'll quit the
[ __ ] podcast
i'll quit the [ __ ] podcast
he's got it he's got it and even if he
doesn't that's a trick
okay he's got it i know he does
you're trying to get me to quit the
podcast but with all this other [ __ ] oh
yeah but crystal did that cancel him he
said this he's a [ __ ] nah i will
cancel it
if one of the property brothers doesn't
have
knight's armor somewhere in the vicinity
of his foyer all right
so it's like
it's just it is what it is but my point
is
you don't have to have a [ __ ]
personality okay you don't have to have
a personality you could just be a guy
who throws a ball oh this is america
dude you can be a guy that throws a ball
you can be a conduct you could be a guy
that just does this to some violence
this is america you want to [ __ ] be
you want to make 200 000 a year by just
doing this with two [ __ ] long q-tips
to some guys with tubas
congratulations
you're in america
that whole donner glover [ __ ] this is
america dude you forgot the part where
you can be a [ __ ] guy that looks like
larry david
with
[ __ ] coffee stirrers and waving him
to a guy who's playing a harp in his
[ __ ] face you walk up there you could
do that and make 200 000 a year
this is america
so you don't have to have a personality
so when i see guys online this is why
i'm talking about the ladies with their
[ __ ] tits out in [ __ ] instagram
and it's like oh make no mistake you
hooking
you want me to really see that jam on
your toast you're really really trying
to promote these [ __ ] watches no
you're hooking
if you have a question about a girl if
she's hooking guess what she's hooking
okay
it's like when you think a guy's gay
guess what
yeah
i like guys
that's him
right he's just peeking out the closet
just [ __ ] seconds at a time
have you ever thought oh i think he's
gay and the guy's not actually gay
you're probably thinking actually yeah
there was one guy
no that guy
is gay
you just don't know it maybe he doesn't
even know it yet
anyway dude russell wilson who by the
way i think is i think he's whatever he
might be but all good you don't have to
have a cur you don't have to have a
personality okay
it's just like
this is what he said okay he
i don't even know how to let me just
play it morning everyone just i know uh
sometimes in life
when you begin
when you okay when you begin it with
some time
i guarantee you just saw like a will
smith video like a [ __ ] uh one of
those videos of will smith saying
something really [ __ ] poetic like you
have to be the person that the people
want you to be and then it slowly chips
away until you can't be that person
anymore and that person you basically in
essence have to kill and then you have
to become you and it's scary right like
that's what will smith said and russell
wilson saw this and then was like i'm
gonna do my own video right
sometimes in life and begin it with the
[ __ ] sometimes in life
we fear we fear what may be on the other
side of pain made it up didn't know he
was going to even end the sentence with
pain guarantee it we fear maybe uh what
may be on the other side of
pain didn't know it was gonna end
you can tell okay so here we go
an injury oh an injury shows up his
broken middle finger
oh man
but the reality about fear is is that oh
here's the reality about confusion it's
not something that's real it's an
illusion it's not something that's real
fear fear is not something that's real
fear who if there wasn't fear there
would be
nine people on this earth because
everyone would have been like a dino
let's check its mouth
fear is essential
do you know why fear's essential for
living if it wasn't for fear there would
be adam and that's it do you understand
eve would have been it's just you need
fear dude
you know when you're [ __ ] walking up
a hill and you're like god this is hard
thank god it's not any bigger if it was
i'd go home
that's basically fear
your fear of losing water and passing
out
how about when you see a shark and
you're scared then what what do you do
you don't go oh it's an illusion chomp
where's my midsection
oops lost my midsection cause i listened
to russell wilson fear is an illusion
and that's why there's knives in my eyes
right now
fear stops you from doing things
that kill you
and here i go here i go again with the
[ __ ] that's so obvious that it's boring
i the whole here let's finish it
unless we make it real if you're not
challenging today whatever you're going
through whatever fear whatever worry
whatever concern you may have whatever
obstacle that you're gonna face today
that you're facing yesterday that you're
gonna face tomorrow
well just run right to it run right
right to it believe that the best days
are ahead believe that you're going to
overcome it all
and keep telling yourself i'm a winner
i'm a winner i'm a winner i'm a winner
love y'all keep going keep winning keep
believing
keep speaking life
the power keep speaking life and death
is in the top that's my favorite part
the power of life and death is in the
tongue
hey
real quick
what
no just real quick pull over i have a
question for you
[Music]
turn the car off
ding ding ding
had to have you do that because i need
your full attention when i ask you this
question
what
dude russell wilson how much does
russell wilson look like a [ __ ] a kid
that you'd sleep over their house when
you were younger and then [ __ ] only
do it once and never [ __ ] see him
again after that
dude he does
[Laughter]
dude russell wilson still looks like a
guy with that your parents would be like
why don't you hang out with russell
anymore dude that's so [ __ ] true
wow dude russell wilson so looks like a
guy that you'd be in [ __ ] for real
second grade and you'd be like mom can i
sleep over russell wilson's house and
they'd be like yes and then you do it
and then you'd [ __ ] do it and then
you just kind of like fizzle out your
friendship after that ah dude
i call him [ __ ] hot man he looks like
that kid all grown up guarantee it
happened to him so many times in real
life
fear is an illusion
hey check out that dinos mouth
i mean dude this whole [ __ ] you don't
have my point is you don't have to have
a personality just chill baby throw a
ball
oh you got injured
that's cool chill until you can throw
the ball again
that's all good dude i know many many
ball players i know many ball players
they're all [ __ ] stupid
jokes jokes
don't have a walkout
don't have a walkout mlb i'm joking i
went to two dodger games last week i'm
joking all ball ballplayers are not
stupid alright
jose canseco
yes
all ballplayers no
some are very smart right
one time i was at a basketball game and
my dad we were talking about
porn you know and uh and i i mean i was
[ __ ] so young and my dad was like
yeah i don't know i don't think people
who do porn are really are that smart
and i was like really that's kind of a
blanket statement i'm like porn a porn
girl
i was like porn actors and actresses
they can be smart and he's like yeah i
mean you know what you're right they can
be smart but then it's like even if they
are smart and they could do something
like really smart with their brain then
they think you know what [ __ ] it i'll
just get my face [ __ ] all over it
instead and then that's not that smart
and i'm like huh
you have a great way of putting things
dad
even if they are smart they still choose
to get [ __ ] all over their face all the
time i was like the meme with the
[ __ ] guy
dad can we just watch the lakers
[ __ ] [ __ ]
fear is an illusion
ah i can't breathe i'm underwater i'm
scared i'm gonna die [ __ ] it i'll drink
it all
you know what i mean fear saves you um
fear saves you i'm next topic
fear saves you anyway i um so
it's all good fierce
dude the trump [ __ ] thing that i
already clicked out of god damn it i'm
such a piece of frank and [ __ ]
i really am dude i took me so long to
find it here it is
here it is
here it is oh my god
uh
[Music]
trump's
thing about colin powell powell god damn
it i can't say names dude colin powell
also just have your name be colin okay
so [ __ ] annoying i know you died and
[ __ ] and i want to be respectful but
like colon dude
jesus christ your name's colin i mean
come on
it's like naming your kid [ __ ] anus
ring
anyway i know but it is though okay
i know i get it i i'm sorry but it is
your boy speaks the truth he can't hold
back
sorry sorry sorry i
oops
sorry i can't hold back
[Laughter]
but it's like naming your kid anus ring
but respect he died and you know what
people are saying he's a war
monger and
he's a war criminal and [ __ ] like that
and i get it but those guys need to make
hard decisions and i don't know dick
okay
yeah but he did this and this and that
yeah but you know what i don't know dick
if nobody i'll tell you what if you're
that high up on the political chain and
people aren't dying on your watch
you suck
you gotta kill some people you gotta if
you're at the top you gotta
you gotta [ __ ] mow
peoples down i mean it's not i'm not
talking about the yeah put cyanide in
his drink i'm talking about that gun
[Music]
in predator
with a [ __ ] dude just uh
i mode it bro you think they're [ __ ]
no way dude they're
both doge and peoples are less
if you're not doing that you suck and
that's how it is period
all right every president ever since
[ __ ] you know what i mean george
washington
well if he wasn't president [ __ ]
hundreds of thousands of people wouldn't
have died no [ __ ] that's that's life
you gotta mow people's down
whether you're
george bush or
or anus ring powell that's life
you gotta mo groups of people down
i'm not talking about groups like five
or six i'm talking about hundreds of
thousands
that's life and oops unfortunately
that's death let me get the gatling gun
and just mow down the first few lines
i had to make a tough decision
it may have been wrong
but that's live
that's life
i went rat had tat into many peoples
[Laughter]
there was nothing i could do i had to
make a decision really quick
because my
ego made me
and everyone has one and just because
i'm a powerful person they think i need
to make a moral adjustment in .02
seconds
that's life
i'm oh many people's down and yes most
of them are brown but most of the people
in the world are brown in my defense i
didn't mean to make em that shade of
color all of them but i just
i just mowed them down and those were
the ones that were in the way they just
happen to be in the area where the brown
people are that's life
by the way i'm also brown too
pretty soon everyone in the world will
be brown anyway
dude it's like come on dude
slive
i'm gonna sell that song
and i'm gonna
and i'm gonna be on the cover of the cd
and yeah
i'm making a a cd
and a laser disc and an eight track
and on the cover of it it's gonna be me
in a general's outfit with [ __ ] guns
that go
and on it there's gonna be bodies piling
up in the background and i'm gonna be
making this face
life
i killed whoever was in the way
that was giving me pushback on my
overall objective that's life
i'm anus ring powell anyway dude how is
what i'm saying right here less
disrespectful than what trump puddin's
ladder
dude donald trump everyone i love here's
the deal dude okay and i'm not gonna say
the thing about how i talk [ __ ] about
everyone so don't get mad at me for
talking [ __ ] about cause i do i talk
[ __ ] about everyone but we're not gonna
say it though
but every time i say look hey [ __ ] this
president people say why don't you talk
[ __ ] about that but i don't do this
because when i do this some people say
you know you don't have to do that
before you preface it so i'm not gonna
do it
dude
trump you thought it would
trump is just like hell and i forgot
that's what he's like
oh you oh y'all oh y'all thought i was
finished
trump's like [ __ ]
trump's like after the first freestyle
this is him
that's trump dude and you're just like
what's he got now
trump's like right before ace ventura
went on that rant where he was like
soccer style kicker dude trump's like
that guy he's like
it's unbelievable dude
trump got voted out and he became a
super scion you know what i mean saiyan
whatever the [ __ ] i don't know who cares
it's dorky that's live your boy's 41
years old he doesn't know the difference
between anybody who's a cartoon a
japanese cartoon with high hair
and um
dude he was just like this is what he
said about colin powell's death be
respectful you're not a comedian you're
a [ __ ] i'm having a [ __ ] political
walk out have a political walk out
because this happened
so trump
does this this is what he said
on the thing and i don't have it again
ah yes dude i love what my computer
[ __ ] up oh here it is um
statement by donald j trump this is his
statement 45th president of the united
states of america by the way these are
the things that [ __ ]
let me just say no i'm not even gonna
say i'm not gonna read them but the the
uh obama and bush put out like really
eloquent things you know what i mean say
what you want about either of them but
they put out really eloquent things when
people die okay trump this is what he
wrote
wonderful to see colin powell who made
big mistakes on iraq and famously
so-called
weapons of mass destruction be treated
in death so beautifully by the fake news
media
hope that happens to me someday he was a
classic rhino if even that always being
the first to attack other republicans he
made plenty of mistakes but anyway may
he rest in peace dude the only nice part
is the last four words
but anyway
[Laughter]
dude
starts it with wonderful which is a sir
[ __ ] angry wonderful great oh great
wonderful wonderful to see colin powell
who made big mistakes on iraq by the way
and famously so-called weapons about
destruction
it's wonderful to see him be treated in
death so beautifully by the fake news
media what it's affecting this video
it's beautiful
hope that happens to me so i'm just
saying
you must have made me wrong i hope that
happens to me someday right
because you're vilifying me but what he
did was bad too
so i hope that happens to me someday he
was a classic rhino even if out even if
that always being the first to attack
other republicans and that's fine right
he made plenty of mistakes but anyway
make you rest in peace
and then grabs someone
not his donut and walks away and the
guy's like
that was mine
dude
by the way that what i just read was
what trump said that was how i would do
like sides to auditions when i would
audition for stuff and the stuff that i
got
was you know they don't want this [ __ ]
bro you want good acting bro you come to
me man you come to me you want good
acting well done all got acting in me
corner huh
i'll go acting in my corner
right you come to me dude you want that
[ __ ] regular acting where somebody's
like the fifth lead on csi and they're
like well i don't know the roommate's
been done all week or do you want a god
dude that's the thing i saw a [ __ ]
clip where gary you people think gary
oldman's good he is good he is good but
let me tell you something he's been bad
like
in the professional
and i know
i know that sacrilege right
it's sacrilege oh by the way that movie
he did the other [ __ ] year where he
won the oscar for it's what's it called
as born as [ __ ]
what's the [ __ ] called he played a
guy would he play capote who do you play
whatever it is a sport of [ __ ]
do you even remember
gary oldman
what
churchill did he play churchill is it
called churchill what's it called
it's part of [ __ ]
hey when i watch a movie like that i'm
like where are the vampires
i don't give a [ __ ] if they didn't exist
in real life none of this [ __ ] did
either you're faking a funk this is
hollywood you won't do [ __ ] yeah
it was called darkest hour yeah no [ __ ]
it was the darkest two
hours as [ __ ] bored as [ __ ] it was
dark for too long because the [ __ ]
lights were out because i was watching
that movie and it was born [ __ ]
and we all know it and you still got a
[ __ ] you know what that was beautiful
that piece that piece was beautiful dude
one time i did a [ __ ] table read with
a like a really really famous director
dude and it was a mini series he came to
see me at the comedy store and he's like
i want you to come do my table read i
was the least famous person there i mean
guys there were so famous and some guys
are dead now but they were so good they
died prematurely because they were
addicted to heroin that's how good these
actors were you understand you know how
good of an actor you are if you died
addicted to heroin in your 40s forget it
bro you got some sort of realness behind
your eyes right you got more realness
when you're behind the camera than you
are when you're like talking to your
wife you know that's where you go to
feel real
you know what i'm talking about
and that guy i'm not going to say his
name but it rhymed with philip p moore
kaufman
and dude i did that table read with the
guy that [ __ ] rhymed with philip p
moore kaufman
and i was the least famous guy there i
actually was
the second least famous guy there but
since then the least famous guy got more
famous than me hey yes dude and that
rhymes with a silo pentagon
so it was me a guy rhymes with
cylopentagilia silla philippe moore
kaufman some woman that rhymes with puma
thurman
and dude just all sorts of [ __ ]
liam skybar all of these that rhymes
with liam skyboy
and dude it was just killer dude and it
was [ __ ] how many
eight hours the read was a mini series
eight hours he wanted to do it all day
i'm not going to tell you who the
director was but he was legendary
he came to the comedy store i started
swallowing nothing i was just like
he's here to see he's
okay i i
right
it's like all of a sudden somebody
dropped the [ __ ] sandbag in my
esophagus he's he's
here to see who it's not sebastian
he's here to see
me
he invited me to his table read and i
did it and it was eight hours long and
it was a mini-series and i don't know
what it was about anymore because time
has passed
and it [ __ ] sucked
dude it was so bad that i was looking
around to the other famous people like
trying to catch eyes you know when like
you're in a coffee shop and somebody
[ __ ] comes in and does some crazy
[ __ ] and you're like well now i have to
make friends with everybody in here
right because that happened it was like
that but nobody was looking at anyone
they were all focused on their [ __ ] and
i'm like dude
you don't understand i've got acting in
my corner as well
but like
why afterwards we close the book dude
and the guy
who rhymes with leab skybar said i'm
just going to say it lip schreiber he
said uh
well this is just a wonderful piece this
is a wonderful wonderful piece and
everyone goes like this yeah
and in my head i go like this oh
i'm built different
[Music]
dude you know like oh i'm oh i'm built
different
the room was so small
dude i was like this next to [ __ ]
milo vent amelia and [ __ ] some other
just so [ __ ] hot in eight hours dude
eight
hours
i know i'm like
and everyone beautiful piece beautiful
piece that's just a beautiful piece and
everyone got we have schreiber yes yes
and this is even before you did that
[ __ ] show where you shoot everyone
yes yes yes
on showtime that everyone says it's a
good show but really no one's seen it
yes yes yes very good
the guy the fixer the show for the fixer
about the guy about the job that's a job
that doesn't exist but you all of a
sudden and it's a dramatic drama and
there's zero comedy in it yes yes
what's that [ __ ] show called roy
donovan dude
don't
have a show
with a like i gotta [ __ ] watch it
like have a show with an alluring title
roy donovan
when somebody oh ray donovan see it
doesn't even matter
roy ray i love how people on the [ __ ]
listening to this [ __ ] were prob some of
them were probably like roy donovan hey
ray donovan's all sort of [ __ ]
ridiculous
right
roy donovan ray donovan i don't give a
[ __ ] call of it donovan mcnabb it
doesn't matter it's all boring at least
donovan mcnamara would have been a real
guy oh dude here it's like dude name
something real name something good
this everyone is on me about
hey watch the [ __ ] show uh succession
not till they change the [ __ ] name oh
but you don't know what you're missing
doesn't matter how about this it doesn't
matter how about this dude
it doesn't matter
it's called succession
it's called [ __ ] succession
like literally
the title
dog [ __ ] would be a better title
i'd be like dog [ __ ] why'd they call it
that
success dude roy donovan is the work
dude the worst title of all time
the commish
that was a real [ __ ] the commish they
shortened it just call it the
commissioner you're not cool usa or
whatever the [ __ ] it was the commish
dude it was the guy who played the thing
in fantastic four
the commish dude roy donovan i can't
like i'm supposed to give a [ __ ] who the
guy is already just hearing his name
dude it's so bad that title is so bad
what's another one that did that what
was the one [ __ ] uh you know what
sometimes they do it with men in history
but it has to be really famous it has to
be really famous otherwise it doesn't
matter what's the one that liam neeson
did the [ __ ] uh michael collins or is
that george whatever it is dude the guy
needs to be super duper famous or it's
like if you don't exist or you're not
super duper famous and you just name
your movie [ __ ] frank [ __ ]
burton
oh you're going to get frank burton
or you know what dude they got a [ __ ]
you know what dude didn't mark who's
that what's that movie mark wahlberg
movie dude i love this podcast
wahlberg wahlberg movie
the new one
joe bell dude is that a real guy doesn't
matter not famous enough call it
something else joe bell dude
also two syllable names are [ __ ]
[ __ ] for real
joe bell brad pitt ruined it after him
don't have a name that's two syllables
i'm brad pitt well now what now what
some guy's gonna be just named frank you
know chuck
there's gonna be a guy named [ __ ] rob
dick what what's the deal i'm brad pitt
i [ __ ] ruined it for real your name
has to be either three syllables or five
syllables that's it i'm done i'm done i
should pretty much end the podcast right
now because i said something so truthful
your first name
or your name
right think about that michael corleone
that's a [ __ ] strong name
right it's a strong [ __ ] name
fictitious but strong we all remember it
not because it's in the greatest movie
of all time which i don't even know
might it be if it came out today would
it still be
i'd rather watch the first halloween
right
michael corleone
that's some strong [ __ ] i'll get you
with
three you can either have da da da or da
da da
george clooney bam
he killed it dude
if you have four syllables okay right
but two is
three is kind of banging five if it's
real strong is super banging
too
hi
i'm joe kent what the [ __ ]
what do you own a law firm locally and
you put out piss poor commercials hi i'm
joe kent and if you've been injured in
an accident you need to call my law
offices now from kent and kent
it's me and my brother
me and my brother do law
dude
i can't believe how [ __ ] lawyers will
be like [ __ ] jacoby and jacoby you
know i know jacoby meyers is one but
like they'll literally be the brothers
and it'll be like [ __ ] [ __ ] and
[ __ ] it's like dude just call it the
dipshit's law firm you know what i mean
dude it's so ridiculous dude
hansel and hansel
here to protect you if you've been run
over by a [ __ ] motorcycle or mack
truck
hey got no legs call hansel and hansel
[ __ ] joe bell eat my ass dude
[ __ ] that that title sucks
michael collins right michael i mean
michael clayton
see
it's [ __ ] michael clayton is it a
real guy he's freed slaves or something
he shot a gun oh michael clayton it's
the [ __ ] george clooney one
liam neeson did one though
movies let's look at let's see if we can
find him
we gotta stop this [ __ ] look at all
these movies liam neeson did all the
same movie unbelievable but he kills it
but he kills it leave the movies he did
taken the marksman ice road honest thief
non-stop taking three take him to the
commuter
look at this unknown cold pursuit uh
unbelievable dude
run all night same movie same movie same
movie he should just come out with a
movie called same movie
and he's just like i already did this
movie but i need to do it again they're
paying me 21 million dollars
rob roy michael oh here it is
michael collins oh i was right there is
a movie michael collins i even get rid
of his like no it's michael clayton also
another movie with a [ __ ] title
here's the here's the one that just
benjamin buttons no
and you're gonna [ __ ] do it and
you're gonna and you're gonna have that
post all right
okay you know what we're done
i just remembered there's [ __ ]
benjamin button we're out okay cool dude
benjamin buttons
and and brad pitt
plays the guy
no
danny devito plays the guy
i'm in brad pitt sexiest man in
hollywood plays it no he's gonna look
all [ __ ] ridiculous as a baby and
gross like an embryo when he's [ __ ]
old no
he ages backwards dude i mean imagine i
know it's based on a book novels should
just stay novels a lot of the time right
because imagine hollywood dude you got
to write that [ __ ] the nuance and [ __ ]
but like when you're in the pitch
meeting
you could just hear these [ __ ]
executives be like so get this
he's born
but he's old
right
and then when he dies
he's a baby
he ages in reverse where's my money
and they go
here it is here's 150 million dollars
that idea
blows donkey dicks here's 150
anyway dude what am i even [ __ ]
talking about anymore i'm done
i'm gonna go watch the movie cruel
i want to watch halloween
we got a nugget dude cal got cal got a
[ __ ] we got a nugget
kristen is like i did something for
calvin i said oh really and you're like
yeah i got it it's a nugget you can fold
it any different which ways it's all a
bunch of pillows it's like nine pillows
and you make it you can make a ford a
hammock a [ __ ] a bank you can make a
bank and go deposit your money in it
it's like oh really and she showed me
how many different [ __ ] positions you
could do the nugget in and then she's
like and by the way it's crazy there's
this [ __ ] parents group on on
facebook or some [ __ ] read it and they
just [ __ ] on nuggets and it's like a
secret society and i'm like hold the
[ __ ] and i'm like that's life
sometimes you get something for your
kids and then you fold it into a bunch
of different fort like sculptures and
your kid has fun on the [ __ ] nugget
and then you put them down and you start
drinking wine and beer and also tequila
that's life
and you're just kind of laying watching
[ __ ] housewives of hollywood and fun
you're [ __ ] nugget and then all of a
sudden you give your wife a look and
then you just all of a sudden starts
sloppy kissing on the drunkalis kissing
on the nugget and then you fold it over
and you realize you could you could
actually have some fun on it and i guess
we'll watch it tomorrow cause we're
gonna [ __ ] on the nugget
it's all about the balance man
anyway dude
calvin seems to be having fun on the
nugget and i'll tell you one thing i'm
never gonna [ __ ] on it so
no that's it
i never really understood the [ __ ]
yeah let's do it somewhere risky
nah
there's beds
yeah you want to do it in the back of
costco what am i a transient
dude this is crazy man
like this is absolutely [ __ ] insane
are you kidding me a bed is for sleeping
and [ __ ] and costco is for moms
that's it
what am i a [ __ ] street urchin
anyway dude you guys are great man we
had a good time and i'm sweating my
[ __ ] nuts off dude can't wait
to get in the shower and um right now i
think i'm gonna take a cold shower but
i'm gonna do the thing that i always do
when i think i'm gonna take a cold
shower i'm going to [ __ ] get in and
i'm going to look at it and i'm going to
feel it and it's going to be too cold
then i'm just going to turn a hot and
[ __ ] abandon that idea that's what i
do all the time yes dude go to
chrisley.com and uh get that merch dude
we're you know what dude this is a cult
don't ever forget it pretty soon we'll
be in the tall [ __ ] blades of grass
sitting indian style wearing
white maybe not white because that's the
kkk but also maybe wearing like light
blue or something like that and we're
just gonna be sharing ideas do you know
what i mean no hate no nothing no
walkouts just chill [ __ ]
and we're gonna have a good time
let's build that log cabin babies hey
guys that's the episode to catch the
rest of the episode going over to
patreon.comcrystalia
and you can get the raw uncut edited
unedited version uh and there's
backlogged episodes also because there's
an episode every month and we've been
doing this for almost a year now uh and
there's backlogged episodes that you can
watch that uh you can sign up for and
it's just six bucks dude so go on over
to patreon.comcrystalia
and uh check all those episodes and the
rest of this episode and have a good day
[Music]
[Laughter]
congratulations
[Music]
hey guys welcome to an ano another walk
hey guys